you know that wallet can only hold so
much money that wallet can only hold so
much money in my pockets can only go so
much money you fill me what's my
[ __ ] name I wish to do Gaza
should boy ty dolla sign I'm about to
show you my essential items one of my
essentials when I get on the plane
sometimes I don't even play music I just
used the noise cancellation because we
plan to stuff like a loud and I want to
go to sleep so shout-out to Bose from
making such great headphones certain
times like I'll stay up the whole night
you know make myself tired for the plane
if I want to go to sleep and I can't get
sleepy they don't just like have some
you know cognac or some red wine Chuck
knock me up gotta have the passport to
get where I want to go you know I just
got back from Argentina recently and I
didn't have my passport I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm done you know I got
stuff essentially
this is one of my favorite wallets it's
a my saber one I'll black you can't
really see but the details crazy a
little stars you know got my ID my
credit cards I got some pounds Megan
says I love more beat-up wallet because
it can operate better in your jeans and
[ __ ]
this is another wallet this one really
is like a lock memberships to clubs and
[ __ ] when you go to the airport like if
I go to United or tail to the American
whatever are gonna keep all those cars
here just kids they try to play me when
I come up with my ticket and all these
dudes and they don't really want me in
their suit but yeah [ __ ] I got a
membership use a lot cigarettes I think
a weed Louie the 13 he's got two
different vibes for me it's all one to
the short ones however much time I have
tattoos and smoke weed all day every day
we're in California right now these are
my favorite cones this is the Khalifah
edition just basic cones you know makes
my life easier
you always get a perfect joint when use
these cones I see a lot of people like
to pour the weed you know wherever on
the surface and they just take the
straws and stuff for like like in ten
minutes to make one joint that is not
the way all you have to do is take like
a piece of paper making it to it a
little funnel or whatever and pour the
[ __ ] in you know it takes five [ __ ]
seconds this is my old neck book I like
this one because it has like my pro
tools my fruity loops my emails
everything you know I have the newer one
but the new one you need all those
[ __ ] adapters she gets kind of going
sometimes I love this one right here
you know we ride to the wheels fall off
[Laughter]
it's essential for me to have a book on
me this is the current book I'm reading
right now the power of now by Eckhart
Tolle just keeps me on point I like to
always like have something to read when
I'm on a plane if I wake up and this is
my current book it's really good you
guys should check it out it's a good one
so far I'm only unlike the second
chapter but this dude knows what he's
talking about why couldn't my next
essential is a speaker this one's pretty
big I usually have the smaller one but
this is the new one they just came out
with the boom box by JBL it's very loud
it has a lot of bass I'm in a lot of
dressing rooms all day and I love music
and I always like to have something to
listen to so I [ __ ] with these right now
I'm listening to my brother's serpent
with feet I'm also listening to kids
seacoast Georgia Smith my brother neo
just dropped his new album Memphis may
fire the new Kanye West
yay album you know Drake singles that
he's been dropping Joe Moses the swap EP
hey rocky pushes out possible don't put
me on to Fleet Foxes and like that's
probably like one of the greatest bands
ever heard I'm listening to me and
Jeremiah's new [ __ ] they just drop notch
on a plug model [ __ ] but it's in the
playlist yeah check out my playlist man
boy ty dolla sign never fire wide range
of dope-ass [ __ ] this is a lot portable
jewelry case or when I want to take all
this [ __ ] off in here right now I got
some girls yeah this is my top rule I
guess I don't have my bottom with me
this is my blue grills top in the bottom
blue diamonds pendants this whole jury
thing for me
started when Wiz Khalifa bought me this
chain it's white gold VBS diamonds and
then I put out beach house 3 and my
first thing it was love you better so I
made a Ganga chains for the fans and
then I got two for myself and then I
bought myself my first Rolex that was
pretty dope and then came this ring and
this bracelet in this rain and this
necklace right here did you go my
journey all of these items come from my
backpack except that big guy speaker
this is one of my mini backpacks supreme
you know you can always count on supreme
then have some good [ __ ] that's easy to
carry through airports we do a lot of
traveling the duffle bag bag is too
heavy some [ __ ] with the backpacks for
sure
no guys thanks for checking me out make
sure you check out my new music all
streaming sites right now
[ __ ] boy ty dolla sign I Taylor Ganga
dies the movement stupid stop playing
with us
whoa